all right let's talk about the dragon of
roads I know I know I'm the Islam
Crusades historian guy why am I talking
about dragons well this particular
little known but interesting story
occurs within the context of the long
war between Islam and Christendom and it
involves a dragon and besides I've
looked around on YouTube and I don't see
any decent retellings of this story and
I've done a little bit of a deep dive as
it were in this taale for another
project I'm working on because it deals
with Islam and Crusades and so I figure
at this seasonless time of Christmas you
know take a break from the beheadings
and the Slaughters and the massacres and
let's talk about something a little more
festive like a dragon okay so it's in
the 1330s that this story occurs and
it's in the island of Roads roads is uh
off the nor off the Southwest coast of
modern-day turkey back then Asia Minor
and RADS was the headquarters for the
Knights of the hospital the hospitallers
once they were ejected with the rest of
the Crusaders out of the Holy Land in
1291 so in the 1330s The Story Goes a
dragon started terrorizing the peoples
of Roads their livestock disappeared
some of their Shepherds who uh uh got
too close to the Dragon's Lair which is
said to have been in the marshes or the
swamps near St Steven
Mountain um they also were killed
disappeared etc etc and a number of the
Knights of the hospital the Knights of
St John as they were better known
actually tried to go and slay the dragon
and apparently several of them went and
were killed for
it at any rate word reached the master
of the order helion or Elon the master
and it got to the point where he said
nobody go fight the dragon everyone stay
put and he ban the people of RADS from
going near the marshes or the layer of
the dragon and so forth but one Knight a
French Knight young Knight by the name
of
diadon excuse my French goesan and I'm
going to call him Goan for the rest of
this he's from the region of Goan in
France but this young Knight who had
seen the dragon with his Brethren but
never fought it would not relent and he
devised the plan he would go to Goan in
France his father's castle and trained
himself to fight the dragon so he went
there and created a replica a large
wooden replica the dragon the way it was
described at the time was about 70 ft
tall or long from snout to tail very
scaly typical dragon and he reportedly
created some sort of replica and started
fighting against it but he also trained
two large vicious dogs depending on
which source you look at they could have
been Bulldog type dogs or blood hounds
but very large aggressive violent dogs
he trained them to attack and bite the
underbelly of this replica Dragon
whenever he would fight it and
supposedly he did this for several weeks
and months Etc until the time came when
he went back to roads to launch his plan
so once he had reached roads and he was
ready
to exercise his plan he quote went down
the mountain with his two dogs Advanced
straight to the marsh and haunt of the
serpent which at the noise that he made
ran with open mouth and eyes darting
fire to devour him this is actually from
the Chronicles and from the chief
historian of the uh Hospital of St John
and we'll discuss the significance of
that and he
continues gozan gave it a stroke with
his Lance which the thickness and
hardness of the dragon's scales made of
no effect he was preparing to redouble
his stroke when his horse frightened
with the hissing and stench of the
serpent refuses to advance retires back
and leaps aside and would have been the
occasion of his master's destruction if
he goes on with presence of Mind had not
thrown himself
off the horse then taking his sword in
hand and attended by his to faithful
dogs he immediately comes up to the
horrible stinking beast and gives it
several Strokes in different places but
the hardness of the scales hindered them
from entering and the Furious Beast with
a stroke of his tail threw him on the
ground and would in infallibly have
devoured him if his two dogs according
as they had been taught had not seized
the serpent by the belly which they tore
and mangled with their teeth though it
struggled with all its strength to force
to force them to quit their hold the
Knight by the help of this sucker gets
up and joining his two dogs thrusts his
sword up to the hilt in a place that was
not defended by scales he there makes a
large and gaping wound when a deluge of
blood flows out thus was the great worm
slain and all hailed diodon goes on a
hero his Knights his fellow Knights his
Brethren of the order of St John threw
him on their shoulders and ran clapping
and happy to the master ilon or helon
and told him the great success but wroth
was he and angry the master because this
Knight dared actually break his command
recall the master had banned everyone
from fighting and trying to kill this
Dragon because it had killed reportedly
several Knights and others and it seemed
a pointless Venture and so he was very
angry and this is an interesting point
because it talks about discipline and I
like this personally you know you would
think that everyone would be be happy
and the master should just congratulate
him and everyone should hug and what a
great and joyous event but the master
kept an eye on discipline Vigilant this
is very important and he just blew up on
this young Knight here for example is
the quote again from The Chronicles of
the hospital of the Master's Draconian
response no pun intended which was
ultimately meant to impress upon all his
Knights the importance of absolute
obedience to order remember these
essentially were monks these were the
military orders these were Warrior monks
like the Templars before them the uh
Knights of St John they took three vows
one of which was obedience the other two
being Chastity and poverty but this is
about obedience we're talking about
basically according to this Chronicle
the master said I don't care if there's
a million dragons or I don't care how
many cattle you saved you broke our rule
with discipline and that must be
punished doesn't matter that's more
important than you're slaying this
Dragon so now Envision this his Brethren
Knights have diodon goes on on their
shoulders they're celebrating they're
ecstatic the dragon the great worm
plaguing roads killing people eating
cattle terrorizing everyone has been
slain by their brother and they're
carrying him to the master to show him
so that he can join in in the praise
what does he do he frowns and he starts
yelling at every everyone and this
actually is pretty interesting I kind of
like it because it shows you the
importance of discipline and
obedience uh for these military orders
which were of course lacking today we so
he chides this young Knight and his
fellows and here's what the chronicle
says immediately this strict Observer of
discipline without vouch safing to hear
him or being moved in the least by the
intercessions of the knights sent him
directly to prison the strict Observer
of discipline is the master he sent the
young Knight to prison despite all the
protestations of his fellow Knights
continues he next convened the council
where he represented that the order
could by no means dispense with
inflicting a rigorous punishment on so
notorious a
Disobedience that was more prejudicial
to discipline than the life of several
serpents would have been to the cattle
and inhabitants of that quarter of the
island but the council prevailed that he
should only be deprived of the habit of
the order meaning be kicked out of the
order which was a pretty traumatic event
for a KN of a military order in short
the unfortunate Knight was ignominiously
degraded and there was but a short
interval between his victory and this
kind of punishment which he found more
cruel and severe than death
itself now what's interesting is the
master was really happy he actually
enjoyed and praised what this young
Knight did it was heroic but it was
important for him to show everyone
including the other nights that you
can't just go around breaking rules that
you there is consequences there's a
punishment and even though it pained him
to inflict this punishment he thought it
was necessary so everyone could
understand the importance of obedience
and even the chronicle explains this so
here we go The Grandmaster after having
by this chastisement stripping him of
his habit and throwing him in jail
performed the obligations due to the
preservation of discipline returned to
his natural temper and was pleased to be
pacific and managed things in such a
manner as to make them intreat him make
the other Knights intreat him to Grant a
pardon to the young Knight which he
would have done himself if he had not
been at the head of the order at the
pressing instances made by the principal
commanders He restored him to the habit
and his favor and loaded him with
kindnesses so he just wanted to make a
point a very important point I would
argue which is the importance of
discipline so what you kill a bunch of
dragons we can live with dragons we can
suffer from dragons it's more important
that we have discipline that's the point
see now
then what's the point of this story on
the one hand it's a nice story it's a
fun story you may have heard stories
about dragons but this is an interesting
one we'll get into it on the other hand
I do like the aspect of of The Obedience
and the Disobedience and how it all
worked out it really underscores the
importance of discipline back in those
days all right so what am I trying to
say here am I trying to get you to
believe that dragons exist no like I
said I find it an interesting Tale one
I'd like to share and uh but there are
some interesting factors that we can
look at uh obviously when you look at
the story as I described it and this
attacking the dragon and stabbing it in
his soft underbelly I mean it has
parallels in mythology or what we call
mythology whether it's B Wolf's dragon
or seagar's fafnir
or even tokens many fun dragons of
Middle Earth so first of all the timing
this is the 14th century the 14th
century is not the 8th Century right
14th century is close to what we call
the modern era it only precedes the
Renaissance by a few decades honestly
and the Scientific Revolution and my
point is that people of the 14th century
when this occurred were not
bited scared superstitious Europeans who
any lizard they see turned into a dragon
people were actually cognizant of
reality and they knew what exaggeration
was and uh not many people saw a dragon
not necessarily believing in a dragon
etc etc the second point is this is
recorded in the formal archives of the
hospital of St John this was actually a
rigorous robust organization that took
serious what it included it was very
skeptical these are not against
superstitious people who anyone who
tells them there's a dragon they're
going to say it's a dragon so there's
actually there was some so there's
actually some care taken into what they
wrote and what they believe happened
also it's important to note that whereas
a lot of myths revolve around
ahistorical characters characters that
never
existed uh in this case the characters
did exist the master himself ilon or
helon existed but so did the Knight of
goong the ual dragon slayer Not only was
he a real historical figure he became
The Grandmaster of the Knights of St
John following the master that punished
him and we actually have stories about
him fighting with Muslims and the
Crusade launching The Crusade and etc
etc all the sorts of things that I
normally do write about which is by the
way why I came across this story that
I'm sharing with you so here's just one
example in 1347 Levon the king of lesser
Armenia who was being terrorized by the
Muslims at the time specifically the
mamluks of Egypt having heard of the
great prowess of the Knights of St John
located in roads reached out and spoke
to diodon De Goan and asked him for help
and Aid now the chronicler explains it
this way he says the problem is that the
Armenians the Orthodox Christians were
not in communion with Rome they were
schismatics so technically the Knights
of the hospital Catholic order should
not have uh helped them as schismatics
but again according to the chronicle
even though leavon was a schismatic as a
Chronicle calls him Goan our dragon
slayer quote full of zeal and animated
with the spirit of his institution
thought it his duty not to abandon any
Christians to the fury of those
Savages and then he prevailed upon the
Council of the order of St John to send
troops into Armenia and he himself
headed them and they ended up fighting
and beating back and repulsing the
mamluks the Muslims of
Egypt despite all that it's sort of
interesting to note that on his actual
tombstone he died in
1353 he's remembered by the words that
are inscribed on it which
are extinctor
draconus which is basically signifying
that here lies the dragon slayer now we
can get into other reasons why this tale
is not pure mythology for example again
according to the records one jean thot
who died in 1670 1667
sorry he wrote that he saw the skull of
the Dragon when visiting roads and that
and that it was quote much bigger and
larger than that of a horse its mouth
reaching from ear to ear big teeth large
eyes the holes of the nostrils round and
the skin a whitish gray occasioned
perhaps by the dust which it gathered in
the the course of time for me however
the most compelling and interesting
evidence has to do with the fact
that RADS from of old was known as a
nest of dragons and Vipers and this
would be centuries before the knights
settled the Knights of St John settled
in roads so for example writing in the
first century BC that is 14 centuries
before the dragon slaying anecdote I
just shared with you the Greek historian
deodor culus noted that quote the land
of Roads brought forth huge serpents and
these serpents caused the death of many
of the natives and then he talks about
the hero forbus Who quote destroyed the
serpents and after he had freed the
island of its fear he made his home in
roads but he's not the only one so the
Latin language Roman authored
astronomica which was written during
Christ's lifetime so again we're talking
about 14 centuries before
the slaying of the Dragon of Roads adds
that the constellation that we know as
Opus
ofus which really means Master of the
serpent and which is represented by a
man grappling with a large snake is
based on the aforementioned battle
between the Greek hero forbus and large
Monsters of roads and this is what the
astronomica
relays the citizens of Roads called
their Island overrun by a great number
of snakes opusa which is translated from
Greek as land of serpents in this
multitude of beasts was a snake of
immense size which had killed many of
them and when the deserted land began
finally to lack men forbus carried there
by a storm killed all the beasts as well
as that huge snake since he was
especially favored by Apollo the God he
was put among the constellations shown
killing the snake for the sake of praise
and commemoration so the point is roads
from of old had a reputation of being a
nest of vipers large snakes and
Serpentine creatures so much so that one
of our constellations today is named
after the dragon slayer or the sake or
the snake killer of roads this same
forbus it's also interesting to note
that a lot of
Scholars uh I'm I'm quoting one from the
17th century and linguist say that even
before the Greeks the Phoenicians and
other early semites refer to the land of
RADS as gaser Rod which is translated
into the aisle of
serpents in short it seems fair to say
that diodon de go on the knight in
question the KN of St John of the
hospital fought and grappled and killed
some sort of large Serpentine creature
maybe alligator like perhaps some sort
of extinct descendant of these large
worms that once infested and plagued
roads as I already mentioned however it
is not my intention to get you to
believe in dragons I just think this is
an interesting story like I said I don't
see it on YouTube it's not really being
mentioned it's kind of stuck right in
there in the chronicles of Islam and
Christendom at War it's more recent than
the usual dragon stories bolf at all and
besides it's Christmas time and I don't
want to talk about beheadings and
whatnot this has a u tied feel to it in
accidentally if you managed to watch the
entirety of this video without chuckling
at my rather outlandish yet seasonally
appropriate attire congratulations other
than that Merry Christmas